okay so spider-man know a home has one
of the most impactful endings that i
think we've had in a comic book movie
since the snap dusted 50 of our life in
the universe whereas that removed
several people from reality peter in
this movie has himself taken from the
memories of everyone that ever met him
completely alone in the world he now no
longer has anyone or any semblance of a
normal regular life the film ends with
him fully in the spider-man persona and
even though he promised to remind mj ned
about who he was he decides against this
but is there a chance that they will
remember him on their own well that's
what we're gonna be discussing in this
video thanks to deadline we now have a
full copy of the shooting script and
i've gone over it using my spoiler sense
to determine exactly what the final
scene means given this new context if
you enjoy the video then please hit the
thumbs up button and also make sure you
subscribe to stick around for videos
like this each and every day without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into spiderman no way home
okay so the film culminates with all of
reality tearing open as people from
every universe start to come into the
mcu amongst the skyline we can catch
villains like craven the hunter and also
the scorpion realizing that they're all
coming there because they know that
peter parker is spider-man he asks
strange to cast a new spell that goes
far beyond the one earlier in the film
now for the first part of the video i
want to talk about how this works and in
turn it'll help us to understand the
line in the script that comes when he
reunites with mj the spell itself is
very much just a form of hypnotism that
puts a block on someone's memory so that
when they try and record something they
just can't remember it you might
remember in the 1990s that everyone
forgot about dre but come this song
forgot about dre we all started to
remember him memory itself is a funny
thing and just in the same way that you
can remember writing a paper in school
about why batman and robin was the
greatest movie ever made you can't quite
put your finger on why that is or
exactly what you said spoiler alert it
was the bat nipples now we've all been
to parties where we got a bit too much
into the mary jane and though we can
remember being there we can't remember
what was said or the events that
happened just in case my mom's watching
this i'm not talking about me there just
talking about my mate henry spoilers and
using all those stories as an example
anyway this is very much how people
remember peter parker if he's interacted
with them in the past they'll somewhat
remember being at that location and
around him but they won't really
remember him specifically he's basically
the support act for the band that you
went to see when you were 13 you can
remember it happening but can't name
them or any of their songs peter is a
blur just a fog that no one really
remembers this is why mj has the black
dahlia necklace in the final scene and
why she's still holding onto it she
knows it's important to her and that it
means a lot but she can't put her finger
on exactly why it means so much to her
she just knows that it's special across
the board people no longer recognize him
and this is also seen in happy hogan who
meets peter at aunt may's grave also
makes you wonder who paid for aunt may's
funeral and grave and peter probably saw
the bill and was like yeah i'm gonna
make everyone forget i ever existed
peace
now even though the pair spent a lot of
time together he still doesn't even
remember that he's connected to may in
real life there's actually a condition
called prosopagnosia or facial blindness
which i'm going to be saying from now on
as i can't pronounce that word for [ __ ]
now this normally affects people from
birth though it can develop if someone
sustains a head injury it stops us
affected from recognizing people's faces
and it can have a massive impact on
someone's life in terms of building
relationships it's a very tragic thing
not to be able to recognize the ones you
love and similarly those on the other
end of this will of course feel distant
seeing that the person they love doesn't
recognize them either this is very
similar to what the world and mj has
become because of the spell which has
completely hypnotized them all however
like with all hypnosis it is possible to
snap out of it and there's a line in the
script that hints to her potentially
doing this of her own accord on page 178
of the script we get a section that
talks about how mj has a slight sense of
deja vu and this is further expanded
upon in the next page in the movie you
might remember if no one has done a
spell on you that their last meeting is
full of purpose though peter goes said
to tell mj everything about them he
decides not to after seeing the cut on
her head much like the resolution at the
end of the first spider-man movie peter
has realized that those closest to him
will always be put in danger because of
the life that he leads thus he decides
to leave the donut shop with just his
coffee but there is a line that says she
has a faint sense of recognition this
comes after he's introduced himself and
he also talks about ned and the pair
getting into mit couple with the deja vu
line i do think that eventually mj will
remember him of her own accord and
she'll break this spell herself in the
comics the love between peter and mj was
so powerful that mephisto himself wanted
to steal it away so you can bet that in
the mcu the pair would have had the
connection to break any form of hypnosis
thinking about it i actually don't think
that peter would ever put her in danger
again and though he could tell her at
any point he never will the power he has
and the responsibility that comes with
it is too much for him to ever pull her
into it and therefore from a narrative
point of view i think it has to be her
who ends up remembering him now this
massively changes the ending and it very
much means that mj will likely be the
one who breaks the spell and that she
will remember him because of this you
have to wonder how far this extends
beyond just her the deja vu is clearly
set off upon encountering peter and you
have to wonder whether happy could get
an inkling of this as well though he
doesn't properly introduce himself like
he does with mj perhaps if the pair met
again at the grave happy could remember
him over time this could extend to the
avengers and anyone that he'd come
across from his whole life including
doctor strange i am really interested to
see what direction that things go and
personally i actually think that we
won't see mj on ed in the next film the
pair are going to mit and boston along
with flash thompson and with peter
studying for his ged i think he'll
remain in the city this could set things
up like him bumping into the mcu's gwen
stacy and also getting the symbiote
which was teased at the end of the film
i absolutely love this scene and having
the added notes in the script definitely
helps to flash the entire feeling of it
we even have one that talks about how
the old guy there is supposed to be a
stanley lookalike which i think adds a
lot to the scene when the film first
came out many people wondered who this
old man was and it's only upon the full
cast being revealed that we now know
it's edward force there was a lot of
debate over whether this was an intended
stanley cameo and now because of the
script we know that in some ways that it
was supposed to give us that feeling
thinking about it on a deeper level we
look at this actor and in many ways get
memories of stan even though it isn't in
fact him audiences might even stare at
him trying to figure out who he is and
where they know him from because he
evokes the sense of the grey comic book
writer this is very much how mj feels
about peter 2 much like her she's there
trying to figure out where she
recognizes this person from and why they
bring back memories it's a great little
touch and it helps to just elevate this
ending even more the last paragraph in
the script also adds a lot more context
to that final swing whereas i initially
thought that the ending was incredibly
tragic the notes point out that peter
now has a new sense of freedom rather
than having to juggle two lives at once
he can't be liberated and knowing that
spider-man lives on even if peter parker
is no more no longer will he have to
worry about those around him getting in
danger and he can finally embrace his
destiny as your friendly neighborhood
spoiler man there is a possibility that
black hat could be pulled into it too
and if we look at the comics i actually
think that she'd be the perfect love
interest to bring into the series
felicia was always more in love with
spider-man than she was with peter and
with him being erased that would be a
great way to take things one final note
is that it says the suit is new for him
but reminiscent of the ones he's seen
before in meeting toby and andrew's
version he's very much bridged the gap
between the pair and has created his own
suit that pulls parts of theirs though
we only get little glimpses at it i
think the new suit looks incredible and
something that's perfectly in line with
how he is in the comics i love finding
all these little details and i
definitely recommend that you read the
full script as it's packed with a lot of
extra info on the movie that definitely
makes the experience even better i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we're in a competition right now
and giving away three copies of the june
box set on the 28th of feb and all you
have to do to begin with the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the video we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want some
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of our thoughts on the
batman and why it's gonna be the perfect
dog night film that'll be linked on
screen right now and hopefully i'll see
you over there after this but if not i
hope you enjoy the weekend thanks for
watching through the video i've been
paul you've been the best i'll see in
the next one take care peace